bonjour et bienvenue dans europe hebdo
au parlement européen ici à bruxelles et
focus dans cette émission sur erasmus
qui a bien failli disparaître nous irons
en angleterre à la rencontre d'étudiants
qui suivent ce programme emblématique de
l'europe mais tout de suite l'actualité
avec cette question l'europe de la
défense existe t-elle nous recevons le
général patrick de rousiers il est le
président du comité militaire de l'union
européenne une question qui se pose
après l'intervention de la france au
mali
nora m'a dit après quelques semaines de
combat les militaires français et
maliens ont repris ko puis tombouctou
l'objectif désormais consolider les
positions et permettre le déploiement
des troupes africaines 5000 hommes en
provenance du tchad du niger du sénégal
ou encore du burkina et l'europe que
fait l'europe
ah oui l'union va déployer la mission
utm au mali une mission de formation
prévue depuis des mois mais resté dans
les cartons
elle ne sera déployée finalement qu'à
partir de mi février un peu tard non
du côté de la france si les belles
paroles de soutien sont nombreuses
l'appui effectif c'est plutôt du bout
des lèvres non quelques avions
ravitailleurs quelques livraisons
d'armes et de munitions quelques
renseignements quelques hommes mais pas
de combattants à beaucourt
alors la france est-elle seule au mali
alors pour répondre à cette question
nous sommes avec le général patrick de
rousiers bonjour bonjour alors vous êtes
le président du comité militaire de
l'union européenne vous êtes de
nationalité française mais aujourd'hui
c'est avec la casquette européenne que
vous allez nous parler et c'est la
première fois que vous donnez une
interview à la télévision depuis que
vous avez été nommé en fin d'année 2012
donc merci d'accorder la primeur aux
chaînes parlementaires françaises s'il
avoue pourquoi n'y at-il pas donc au
mali des soldats des combattants avec
sur l'épaule le drapeau européen
permettez-moi d'abord de préciser mon
rôle en tant que président du comité
militaire président du comité militaire
c'est le porte parole des chefs d'état
major des armées des 27 chefs d'état
major des armées
c'est le conseiller militaire de madame
ashton et de l'ensemble de la structure
du service européen d'action extérieure
la massonne ok là où tu représentes la
route et qu'on entende le ministre des
affaires étrangères de l'europe
tout à fait et puis c'est la personne
qui doit aider à bâtir du consensus
parce que un engagement européen c'est
un engagement solidaire de l'ensemble
des vingt-sept et donc c'est créer les
processus les discussions les échanges
qui vont permettre aux 27 de se forger
collectivement une idée est de s'engager
dans le cadre du mali l'europe lors de
la défense et active est active depuis
longtemps et s'engage s'engage avec
détermination
aux côtés du mali aux côtés des forces
africaines qui vont s'engager et bien
sûr aux côtés de la france mais vous
dites elles s'engagent activement mais
il ya des soutiens logistiques et une
dizaine de pays qui ont rapporté par
exemple des avions ou des moyens
logistiques mais la france est seule à
se battre ceux qui prennent des risques
ceux qui peuvent mourir
ce sont des soldats français comment on
peut expliquer ça c'est une décision de
la france de s'engager qui a été saluée
par l'ensemble des pays européens lors
d'un dernier conseil avec les ministres
des affaires étrangères c'est la france
et le mali qui est au combat pour
qui perd et l'intégrité territoriale du
mali mais c'est accompagnée par une
solidarité et une inscription dans la
durée
c'est cette inscription dans la durée
qui est très importante au plan européen
qui est un signe fort d'engagement et
qui est important pour la stabilité du
sahel dans son ensemble puisqu'il s'agit
de développer tous les outils qui sont
les outils qui vont permettre à la force
africaine de se déployer
c'est pour ça qu'il ya eu une crise
grâce une structure des changes
permettant de savoir quels étaient les
besoins des pays africains en terme
d'équipement en termes de transport pour
pouvoir aller au mali et puis c'est
l'aide aussi bien sûr que l'on peut
apporter à titre bilatéral mais ceux ci
étaient le fruit d'une prise de
conscience collective qui a été forgé
bien sûr dans les dialogues bilatéraux
entre paris et les capitales mais aussi
ici à bruxelles dans les instances que
ce soit au comité militaire où que ce
soit dans les réunions avec les
ambassadeurs pour montrer l'importance
de cette zone et l'importance pour
l'europe
alors si l'europe fait autant de choses
que que vous le dites
aujourd'hui évidemment on veut bien
croire mais comment se fait-il qu'il y
ait par exemple en france est cette
polémique qui ne cesse pas depuis
maintenant 15 jours depuis le début des
frappes françaises sur le mali sur
justement cette absence européenne
comment vous expliquez ça vous je crois
que c'est peut-être un défaut pour de
notre part nous européens et merci de
nous donner l'occasion d'illustrer ce
qui se fait lorsqu'on peut être ne
communiquent que tous n'ont pas assez
pour faire permettre à chacun de
percevoir ses engagements l'europe est
engagée depuis longtemps au mali en
termes de développement en termes d'
aide humanitaire
elle a défini récemment une stratégie
pour le sahel
elle a maintenant la décision de
s'engager pour une mission ultime mali
longue de formation de la nouvelle armée
malienne
une armée qui doit être sous l'autorité
bien évidemment du gouvernement civil et
qui doit s'inscrire dans le cadre des
règles internationales d'engagement
vis-à-vis d'une population c'est ce qui
va se bâtir progressivement et c'est
pour ça que cet engagement européen est
important il est important parce qu'il
s'inscrit dans la durée sur 15 mois
alors ce qui est du volet militaire vous
avez parlé de cette cette mission dont
qui utm donc en fait c'est une formation
une mission européenne
deux formations qui d'ailleurs dirigée
par un général un autre général français
le général lecointre est-ce que vous
pouvez nous donner des détails déjà
risque par exemple on connaît les dates
précises de mise sur pied de cette
formation au mali la décision de
lancement de cette mission devrait être
prise au milieu du mois de février vers
le 12 février donc très prochainement en
fait avec dès le début dès cette date là
la première partie de des actions qui
seront menées auprès du mali mais
parallèlement à ça il ya tout le reste
des activités qui sont menées par
l'union européenne il y a en ce moment
bamako une délégation de l'union
européenne avec à la fois la commission
et le service européen d'action
extérieure pour identifier quelles sont
les évolutions dans les actions qui
seront menées en termes de développement
en termes d'utilisation de la facilité
de la paix pour l'afrique un certain
nombre de contributions qui vont
permettre d'aider à la stabilisation de
la situation
non pas au plan militaire le plan du
développement partir la question se pose
effectivement de savoir s'il fallait se
remettre comme c'était le cas auparavant
il avait été arrêté à aider
financièrement ce pays tout à fait après
le coup d'état et il y a eu la décision
par l'union européenne d'arrêter
l'ensemble des investissements qui
étaient effectués d'abord pour créer une
pour analyser aussi pour faire une
pression vis-à-vis de l'ensemble de la
population et mais surtout du
gouvernement et puis pour qu'il y ait
une feuille de route cette feuille de
route du gouvernement a été est en cours
de finalisation et va permettre un
investissement beaucoup plus important
et dans la durée dans tous les secteurs
puisqu'il s'agit de restaurer un état de
droit dans un pays qui a été
profondément bouleversé ces derniers
temps c'est ce que l'on fait un peu
partout l'union européenne fait ça bien
sûr au mali c'est ce qui est au coeur de
l'activité de l'actualité en tout cas de
chacun mais c'est le cas aussi dans la
corne de l'afrique la corne de l'afrique
est illustratif haussier de ce que
l'union européenne peut apporter
alors ce n'est pas que le volet
militaire mais aussi tous les autres
volets une question quand même sur le
volet militaire
il existe ce qu'on appelle dans un bon
français les battle group le battle
group donc en fait un groupe ii
deux mille hommes je crois un groupe
européen de 2000 hommes qui normalement
devraient pouvoir intervenir sur des
terrains d'action extérieure ce qui est
ce qui aurait pu être le cas là au mali
ça s'est pas fait en fait ce groupe
n'est jamais intervenu ce que vous
pensez qu'il a encore une utilité
les contacts et quand une utilité ils
ont une utilité parce que c'est d'abord
la démonstration d'une volonté des pays
européens d'avoir en permanence en
alerte
quelques jours une capacité permettant
de déployer dans tous les cas que ce
soit y interviennent jamais parce qu'il
faut l'unanimité des 27 pour que pour
qu'ils interviennent donc c'est souvent
un peu long le cadre bien évidemment et
celui de limiter ces longs ou courts
selon les situations
il se trouve qu'au mali ça n'était pas
appropriée ça n'était pas approprié
parce que l'engagement était un
engagement d'une nation qui a conduit
dans les premières heures avec une
réactivité qui devait être immédiate
cette réactivité bien sûr immédiate elle
ne veut pas être apportée par n'importe
quelle organisation quelle qu'elle soit
multinationales et donc l'union
européenne aurait pu intervenir si les
événements avaient été différents avec
son groupement tactique bien évidemment
l'analyse a été effectuée ici à
bruxelles
ça n'était ni une demande du mali ni une
demande de la france et donc ce n'était
pas ce qui a été envisagé mais ça ne
veut pas dire que ce n'est pas utile
parce que outre le volet gauche venait
d'évoquer est aussi l'interopérabilité
entre les forces européennes qui est
très utile puisque c'est ce
développement des groupements tactiques
qui leur permet de mieux se connaître à
la fois sur le terrain les soldats mais
aussi dans les structures décisionnelles
alors je voudrais vous poser une
dernière question et si c'est possible
mais que vous puissiez me donner une
réponse synthétique est ce que vous
pensez que l'europe de la défense dont
on parle beaucoup aujourd'hui existe
j'ai envie de dire tout de même l'europe
de la défense existe le service
opérations extérieures est actif dessine
une crise soir réunissent très
régulièrement pour analyser les enjeux
pour définir des objectifs pour ensuite
pouvoir discuter entre ambassadeurs au
comité militaire d'options de telle
sorte à ce que collectivement les
vingt-sept décide d action ti punch est
mené et bien merci beaucoup d'avoir
accepté notre invitation patrick de
rousiers d'avoir apporté des
éclaircissements sur cette europe de la
défense
l'europe qui se demande aujourd'hui si
elle va continuer avec ou sans la grande
bretagne savait que david cameron a
récemment fait un discours dans lequel
il évoque un référendum sur la sortie de
son pays de l'union européenne alors
nous avons voulu avait savoir avec
aurélie d'afas ce qu'on pensait les
télévisions européennes et ensuite nous
reviendrons avec un invité un confrère
britannique regarder
l'union se construire à tel demain sans
les britanniques la question inquiète
l'europe et divise le royaume uni
l'opposition attaque david cameron
pourquoi ne peut-il pas dire de façon
claire qu'il votera oui au référendum
parce qu'il a peur des gens qui sont
assis derrière lui la seule chose qui a
changé par rapport à il ya quelques mois
lorsqu'il s'était prononcé contre un
référendum
ce n'est pas la situation en europe mais
la situation au sein du parti
conservateur
pourquoi ne l'admettent il pas sa
conduite édicté non par l'intérêt
national
mais par son parti david cameron réfute
toute position isolationniste
mais sur les télévisions européennes
l'atmosphère est opé finances david
cameron s'est engagé de tout son coeur à
défendre le maintien du royaume uni dans
l'union européenne
mais si les citoyens de ce pays décide
de sortir ils auront pris une décision
irréversible comme l'a dit cameron
ce sera comme acheter un aller simple
sans retour possible un aller simple une
solution perdant perdant pour la rtbf
avec des conséquences financières
aujourd'hui la city joue sur deux plans
elle joue sur le premier plan qui est sa
valeur internationale et sur le deuxième
plan qui est sa valeur de faire parti du
marché unique
si demain on lui retirait sa deuxième sa
deuxième valeur ajoutée de faire parti
du marché unique
il n'est pas certain qu'elle
conserverait sa première valeur ajoutée
d'être une d'être une place financière
internationale
et la grande bretagne ne serait pas la
seule perdante une union européenne sans
les britanniques risquent aussi d'être
affaiblie alors comme promis nous avons
été rejoints par charles bremner bonjour
bonjour alors vous êtes rédacteur en
chef europe le correspondant ici à
bruxelles du times j'ai envie de dire
une question personnelle pour commencer
depuis le discours de david cameron il
ya maintenant quelques jours
est-ce que vous en tant que britannique
vous êtes perçu un peu différemment ici
à bruxelles pas vraiment parce que les
britanniques ont toujours été mauvaise
élève le mauvais élèves de l'union
européenne
comme vous savez il ya un peu de fatigue
sur la question la question britannique
pas maintenant on va dominer ma mère est
très présent pendant des années à venir
est ce que vous diriez en ce qui
concerne david cameron que ce qu'il a
fait là c'est de l'électoralisme
ou est ce qui a réellement est ce que
nous les autres européens on doit
s'attendre à la sortie du royaume uni de
l'union européenne il ya des deux il y a
de l'électoralisme plutôt les problèmes
internes du parti conservateur depuis 30
ans maintenant le parti conservateur est
divisé par la question de l'europe ce
n'est pas vraiment une question qui
excite omc de les britanniques en
général mais qui c'est vrai qu'il a une
phobie en général et david cameron et
c'est aussi de lancer l'abcès europe
pour pour tout le pays
est-ce que c'est europhobie est en train
d'augmenter
certainement oui depuis la crise l'euro
leur phobie à passer en maintenant
euroscepticisme passé en majorité au
moins 50% du pays alors avant d'être en
poste ici à bruxelles vous avez fait de
nombreuses capitales dont des capitales
européennes et dont paris est ce que
vous diriez que
il ya les mêmes reproches qui sont faits
à l'europe de bruxelles à londres qu'à
paris est ce que c'est la même chose ce
n'est pas tout à fait la même chose même
le contraire en france c'est très
amusant je n'arrive pas à convaincre mes
collègues à londres que en france
l'union européenne est vue comme l'otage
des anglo saxons avec le libéralisme le
marché libre tout sa privatisation
parce que pour la grande bretagne
l'union européenne c'est une
construction française pour dominer
l'europe et vous pensez également que
cet euroscepticisme est en train de
monter sur le sur le continent européen
certainement pour pour les un peu les
mêmes raisons c'est-à-dire l'idée que
bruxelles et il n'est pas démocratique
c'est qu'on ne sait pas comment prendre
les décisions qu'ils se mêlent de tout
et que c'est une chose un peu étrangère
dernière question vous pensez que vous
l'avez un peu dit d'ailleurs dans votre
précédente réponse mais que finalement
l'union européenne va maintenant se
tourner vers vers la grande bretagne
c'est à dire dans les années qui
viennent
est ce qu'on est en train d'entrer dans
une période de turbulences politiques
après une période de turbulences
économiques
oui je crois que les deux cents lits et
la turbulence économique l'euro est
directement liée avec la situation
britannique c'est l'euro sert suscitent
les anglais vont devenir moins moins
hostile je pense merci beaucoup
charles bremner d'avoir accepté notre
invitation nous allons perdre et
maintenant d'erasmus erasmus qui est un
programme qui a 25 ans qui est sûrement
le programme européen le plus populaire
chez les jeunes est un programme qui a
eu des difficultés de financement nous
allons maintenant parler avec katia
gilbert et son invité d'erasmus mais
tout de suite
reportage à londres signé paul bouffard
au milieu des flocons de neige tanguy 23
ans loin de sa région lyonnaise
le frenchy s'est lancé dans des études à
l'étranger en marketing international
ici sur le campus de l'université
anglaise de reading à quelques minutes
de londres
aujourd'hui travailler et découvrir ce
que c'est que la vie erasmus ça apporte
beaucoup de choses notamment une
première expérience à l'international
ça permet aussi découvrir de nouvelles
cultures de s'adapter à nous jouer un
nouvel environnement
et puis ça permet aussi une certaine
ouverture d'esprit qui est un prérequis
actuellement dans le monde du travail
de toute façon une expérience
internationale est forcément un avantage
sur les cv erasmus une succès story d'un
quart de siècle
le programme d'échangé ducati a fait ses
preuves il permet aux étudiants
européens de faire une partie de leur
cursus universitaire à l'étranger
près de 3 millions de jeunes en ont
bénéficié
un système qui a fait de la mobilité
étudiante le trait d'union entre pays de
l'union européenne en 1987 l'objectif
était dé veiller l'identité citoyenne du
vieux continent et paroles de
professeurs ça marche encore depuis
quinze ans françoise le saut enseigne à
l'université de reading
l'intérêt est toujours aussi vivace et
des points de vue d'une enseignante dans
une section de langues modernes
je dirais même que le programme erasmus
est devenu absolument essentielles sont
des étudiants qui vont être assidu ce
sont des étudiants qui vont être
enthousiaste qui vont s'exprimer
beaucoup en classe dans les discussions
et dans les débats et qui vont apporter
un point de vue légèrement différent qui
est aussi extrêmement enrichissant pour
les étudiants locaux pourtant ces
dernières semaines à court d'argent
l'union européenne a voulu couper dans
le budget du programme
victimes collatérales de la crise eh
bien non les instances européennes
reviennent sur la décision et propose
même d'augmenter de 70 % le budget sur
la période 2014 à 2020 je crois que les
fonctionnaires de bruxelles n'ont
strictement aucune crainte à avoir
c'est un set un système qui qui a de
beaux jours devant lui
simplement parce que c'est un système
qui s'est rendu absolument indispensable
le royaume uni une terre où meurent au
scepticisme n'est plus légende
et pourtant ici le programme est en
pleine progression
même si les chiffres ne sont pas ceux de
l'espagne ou de la france au british
council organisation gouvernementale
pour l'éducation
on est loin d'abandonner erasmus
christine picking février on est très
content de voir une augmentation du
nombre d'étudiants ces sept dernières
années depuis que le british council
finances ce programme fc on a noté une
hausse de 8% par an du nombre
d'étudiants pour l'année passée nous
avons eu plus de 13 mille jeunes erasmus
c'est un record pour le 25e anniversaire
du programme
preuve que ça marche bien rire les x
games en tout cas clairement s'ils
veulent travailler dans un autre pays
européen c'est un plus pour eux car ils
ont une ouverture d'esprit
mais même s'il reste ici au royaume uni
les employeurs disent que ces étudiants
sont plus matures ils ont plus de choses
à offrir qu'un étudiant qui est resté
chez lui ça lui devenu la maison
tu vois ce soit est ce que je
à reading tanguy vit en colocation avec
d'autres étudiants étrangers
pour eux cette réussite coûte cher être
étudiant erasmus n'est aujourd'hui plus
donné à tout le monde
certains parlent même d'un système
réservé à des étudiants favorisés alors
pour être étudiant asmus il faut avoir
quelques quelques sous de côté parce que
la bourse erasmus ne suffit pas bien sûr
ce que ce que ce que les bourses ne
finance pas c'est mes parents qui
finance alors moi le montant de ma
bourse s'élève à 1500 euros à peu près
pour les neuf mois où j'étudie en
erasmus bora étudiant espagnol de 25 ans
voit dans ce programme une solution pour
trouver du travail en espagne
un jeune sur deux est au chômage alors
lui il pense rester en angleterre en
espagne aujourd'hui c'est pratiquement
impossible de trouver un travail en
angleterre ça me semble plus facile
j'aurai plus de possibilités ici plus
mais look vraiment mon anglais s'est
améliorée vraiment et ensuite avoir un
diplôme validé à l'étranger c'est plus
valorisant que dans son propre pays
m
alors erasmus une solution à la crise
une chose est sûre le programme est
inscrit au patrimoine européen en 2011
deux cent trente mille étudiants ont
bénéficié d'erasmus désormais chaque
année l'objectif sera de permettre à ces
deux cent mille nouveaux jeunes
d'étudier à l'étranger
reportage sous la neige de reading en
grande-bretagne signé paul bouffard et
nous accueillons doris pack merci d'être
avec nous vous êtes députée européenne
venus d'allemagne et vous présidez la
commission culture et éducation vous
êtes battus pour qu'erasmus survival or
le financement est assuré pour l'année
qui vient
mais jusqu'à jusqu'à quand mais cette
fois ci on discute le programme qui
existe encore c'est à dire c'est fini
à la fin de cette année 13 et on va
recommencer avec un nouveau programme
comme avec tous les programmes front
social france structure l agriculture
tout ça on va commencer 2014
jusqu'au 20 est ce qu'aujourd'hui il y a
de l'argent pour erasmus oui on a on a
décidé il ya huit ans aulas est temps
qu'on aura assez d'argent
malheureusement on a on a une habitude
de gérer les budgets c'est difficile à
faire comprendre aux gens je n'arrête
je commence pas donc en tout cas on a de
l'argent ce n'est pas un asthme ce qui
va souffrir et erasmus est dépassé mais
rose musquée éducation d aider la
première jusqu'au jusqu'au même la fin
de la vie parce qu'on a quatre
programmes dedans pour les jeunes des
communes us pour les deux yeux qui font
l'apprentissage c'est leonardo pour les
étudiants erasmus et pour la flandre
leur nid c'est gondeville bon mais
maintenant vous des clés qu'elle est
quel est pour vous le premier intérêt de
tous ces programmes alors de faire
connaître l'europe et l'idée de l'europe
aux jeunes parce qu'ils sont nés dans
une union européenne et qui connaissent
pas l'origine
et c'est surtout les des voix de
soutenir et de faire vivre cette europe
alors depuis berlin françois hollande et
angela merkel ont proposé d'élargir le
champ des races plus ils ont dit en tout
cas un gala merkel a dit il faut que les
ouvriers puissent aussi apprendre une
langue étrangère est ce qu'il faut
élargir erasmus sont fair and erasmus
pour tous alors moi j'étais présent à
berlin je peux dire j'étais très content
de moi j'ai applaudi j'ai commencé à
applaudir
parce que tous les deux
en parler d'éducation il faut pas
élargir parce qu on a déjà élargi depuis
20 ans c'est à dire tout ça existe mais
ce n'est pas assez utilisé et c'est plus
que normal que des jeunes d'ouvriers par
une langue étrangère moi j'habite en
sarre c'est à dire les gens de la
lorraine où les gens de la sarre ils
doivent parler la langue du voisin parce
qu'autrement le marché interne le petit
dont la grande région ça alors luxe
n'est pas utilisée n'est pas à utiliser
donc il faut leur donner la chance de
vraiment travailler à travers les
frontières qui n'existe plus et pas dans
le cadre d'erasmus vous intéresse mais
s'est réservée pour les étudiants wisa
mais pour beaucoup de gens erasmus est
un synonyme pour mobilité erasmus est
vraiment pour les étudiants
leonardo était déjà depuis 20 ans pour
des ouvriers ou pour les jeunes qui vont
ben quand devenir un ouvrier
donc on a aussi d'un programme pour les
impôts des écoliers comenius ça va
vraiment très bien et moi je voudrais
vraiment que quand on sait que plus
d'essais programme parce que ça c'est
vraiment le ferment de notre travail et
en europe est ce que vous pensez qu'ils
sont assez connus et qu'est ce que vous
pouvez faire ici en tant que députée
européenne pour écouler les faire
connaître du grand public
nous on travaille mais on a besoin de
vous pour faire diffuser tout ce que
nous faisons
alors erasmo est connu mais il faut
faire connaître aussi comme je le dis
tout à l'heure à vous on a un programme
de jeunesse pour les violences
volontaires
moi j'ai rencontré 400 volontaires
allemands qui était l'année dernière
n'importe où on est qu'est ce qu'ils
font quand quelqu'un ment il travaille
dans un environnement culture ou aux
santé et environnement
bon ou éducation ils cherchent selon la
commission les aides et donc à la fin de
12 mois aux mêmes six mois ils ont
vraiment une connaissance de l'europe
extraordinaire est ce que ce type de
programme peut aussi permettre à ces
jeunes de mieux s'insérer plus tard dans
le marché du travail alors que oui dois
je n'ai jamais quand même une
préoccupante naturellement aussi vous
aider au sol dans un environnement
étranger vous entendez une autre langue
ou essayer de la comprendre ou de la
parler donc je pense c'est vraiment une
aide essentielle pour la comédie riche
de la globalisation de notre manque donc
alors il faut vraiment qu'on donne
toutes les chances et les gens se
connaissent ses chances là et c'est à
travers les médias on peut le faire
connaître
alors il ya une idée qui circule sur le
financement de ces programmes
hélas certains qui proposent de
d'affecter le produit de la future taxe
sur les transactions financières à
erasmus qu'est ce que vous en pensez
j'ai rien contre vous savez si on
compare le money à la budget qui est
prévu pour l'éducation ensemble pas
seulement erasmus pour les étudiants
mais que tout vote pour tous l'éducation
toute l'éducation alors c'est je veux
dire en anglais un pirate
mais si on augmente ce pirate ce n'est
pas beaucoup mais 60 à ce que ça
représente combien important 1,5 pour
cent donc alors ce n'est rien
donc alors si on augmente comme on a
prévu comme la commission a prévu le
parlement en 70 % c'est ni même pas
beaucoup mais c'est beaucoup pour
l'intérêt d'éducation son pilote qui
peut faire beaucoup comme lui c'est ça
eh bien merci dans l'espace d'avoir été
notre invité interview express puisque
vous devez revenir dans l'hémicycle
merci merci et à bientôt
c'est la fin de cette émission se
retrouve la semaine prochaine avec nora
hamadi à strasbourg très bonne suite de
programmes sur les chaînes
parlementaires
et
à